welcome back to the GameSpot stage here
at e3 2015 I am joined on the couch with
a lovely iJustine hello how are you I'm
very well how you doing doing great
thanks for having me this is amazing yes
thank you for coming honor how are you
how are you holding up it's day 3 this
is what this is when everyone kind of
just kind of flatlines a little bit
slowlyslowly well I feel like I've been
doing this like for the whole week
because we started with the Nintendo
championships on Sunday yeah which was
so much fun I mean watching these guys
do these crazy speedruns especially that
end if anybody watched it oh my god it
was just super intense I know I'm like
I'm really good at that I missed it so I
was I was working or something but I
kept seeing like all the feed and I like
with them a mini shoutcaster as well oh
my goodness he was so amazing so I just
kind of you know I want that guy I want
that guy and his kid to start a channel
face yeah yeah no it was great and it
was really cool because splatoon is such
a fun game too and kind of hearing it
from a kid's perspective yeah and
hearing his take on it and his
strategies I mean it was so much cooler
than you know your usual shoutcasters so
he did such a great job man thing like
we have the Lego dimensions guys on Elia
and they were saying that when they were
playtesting and they were showing and
though the shrinkage kids kids are
playing it in a really different way so
be amazing to hear like kids
perspectives on games like spore toon
where it's not necessarily like the
usual tactics go really no it's awesome
I haven't got to play Lego dimensions
yet that is on my list you know it was
it was there was in it was in arms reach
I didn't steal the Gandalf like I'd
planned to yeah but it looks amazing and
they were showing off the portal level
I'm in love it looks so great because I
mean I love amiibo and I love sort of
like the whole sky Lander on that aspect
of it you know taking these real life
toys and implementing them into the
games it's so much fun and I love
collecting the amiibo I mean if you've
been I haven't actually got to see them
all yet but the view the 30th
anniversary Mario amiibo is so awesome I
like the flat one yes I get 8-bit off
beautiful I alley from Nintendo actually
bought the yarn Yoshi I haven't seen
them yet were they amazing
they were so soft I didn't like just
yeah knitted it me but it was the best
but one of your highlights been from the
show so I did get to play Mario maker
which was actually really really fun I
mean you've seen the demos and all of
that kind of stuff but until you
actually get your hands on it yeah and
you see a level that you have just
and it's so much fun my only complaint
though is I'm left-handed so when I'm
drawing on the Mario maker the hand is
actually right-handed I both thought out
Nintendo if my only complaint I think
we're gonna be all right I love that
video when they were showing mr.
Miyamoto somebody designed this really
difficult level for him and they just
gave it to him and he was like the
problem too is I mean you can make
levels be you know there it is there's
the right-handed Mario maker hand but
it's amazing I mean you can create
anything you want and it kind of gonna
be amazing I think this is gonna change
the game for a lot of like live
streamers oh yes you could watch these
people make the levels and then if
there's this huge social aspect so you
can just share it out and everybody can
play it yeah so what else have you seen
Star Fox was awesome yes so this is a
shed one that we have because I played
stuff did you get a lot of time with it
or did you just feel like a couple
minutes did you know I got - I did
before the show yeah so there's no one
here still failed at the boss like I got
all the way and then you know the last
minute I crashed into it yeah I was
giving a hang of the controls because
it's so different because you're not
only looking at the television but you
also have to look at the gamepad to a
time you have to get the the more
precision accuracy shooting so by the
time I got the hang of the controls it's
like no no I have to go but it was
really fun and I think people are gonna
really love it yeah what else you've
been playing what else I play black ops
3 I got to play the multiplayer
yesterday which it was really fun and
they announced two new specialists here
so it's kind of great I think there's
three more that they have it they're
gonna announce also got a chance to
check out a hololens demo I'm so jealous
when they announced that at the press
conference on the Xbox on Monday I mean
I lost my mind and being there in the
audience and seeing everyone else's
reactions in real life I mean it was
kind of intense and if anybody hasn't
seen this yet it's amazing
it's crazy I mean you will be playing
Minecraft right here and they lifted now
the level up Oh
this was this is a halo yes just a
little demo that they did and when you
put it on my initial reaction I was
absolutely in shock because you saw a
real-life objective line just show up
right in front of you and you were
supposed to follow it I mean is the
headset itself like heavy I mean
wasn't that heavy suprisingly I mean
when you're holding it it's a little bit
heavier but when you put it on
however they have sort of like two
different bands that kind of like match
to your to your head shape so we will
actually pretty comfortable I was really
impressed but it's so different than
oculus because you know you're looking
through the screen and you're actually
seeing real-life so you're not sort of
enclosed in this VR world I think that
is the thing with oculus is that it's
sort of like you also have a level of
fear that you don't bump into anything
exactly um whereas with hololens it's
it's glasses and it's the best of both
it really is yeah it's interesting too I
had Google glass really early so I feel
like this is just a bigger version of
what Google glass really had in mind and
I'm really excited to see but Google
glass this sadly swept under the rug a
little bit but it might be I think when
I think when stuff like hololens takes
off Google glasses and reemerge
triumphantly saying you thought you seen
the last of us it was very early I feel
like crew Google glass but I think that
was a good test into you know like the
consumer market you see like what people
think and what they can do with it and
also I mean how are they gonna make this
stuff look cool like we're out in public
I mean who's gonna be rolling around
with the hololens on my face actually I
probably would so I take that back I
definitely do it within the confines of
my house but you know maybe not to get
like milk from the shop or something who
knows and you're talking about running
into stuff too it's gonna be really
interesting because you can look around
and maybe there's you know an open hole
but it's just sort of appears behind you
maybe you want to walk through it so
you're not really careful
like imagine if I mean like they put
like a portal game or something on it
there we so many people just gonna found
yeah it's gonna be amazing and I think
this really is sort of mean it really is
a game changer and you're gonna be
playing games in a whole new world and a
whole new way and you know one person
even in the Minecraft EMA that they did
you know you can still play with the
person that had the lenses on so I'm
really excited so how was it black ops 3
multiplayer so I really like the reveal
trailer yeah because it was fast-paced
it showed off a lot of different stuff
yeah it was really nice it wasn't just
shoot with gone it was run on walls like
titanfall it was bow and arrow it was
everything yeah and I think a lot of the
complain
she from people when they played
advanced Warfare's no they didn't like
the exoskeleton they didn't like this
with that but I mean I got so into
advanced warfare and so it's I love sort
of that fast-paced game so this black
ops 3 is a little bit slower so I think
for people you know the advanced warfare
might have been too fast or a black ops
2 is a little bit too slow it's sort of
a really nice combination out of two
because you can do I mean you have
unlimited just always feel like you're
running you have all the different
specialists to which you can choose from
so kind of adds another dynamic to the
game where you know you could just kind
of figure out your playstyle and and
yeah it's gonna be really interesting
and the campaign looks awesome - yeah
and played with like a 4 player campaign
coops that's gonna be really fun which
is something that also halos kind of
experimenting with with nathan fillion
1/3 skins fresh face thanks billion
which is cool and you've played that too
right I did yes I got to play war zone
yesterday it was actually it was fun I
mean it's just such a massive level and
Halo has always been such a you know
it's such an amazing game so to kind of
really come back from you know the
Master Chief collection - I think
they're gonna come back in a big way I
think they're gonna be fine I just
didn't think you so much Julie yeah I
have a great rest of show thank you
alright guys make sure you stay tuned
against what calm it goes awesome demos
coming right up